the most amazing story about you that
I've I've always read and I don't know
if it freaks you out
and I don't even know if it's real
but when you were a kid
somebody hit you over the head with a
hammer and I mean really hard who was
that who hit you over the head well I
didn't ask his name right it was a fight
yeah it was in school and I was about 15
and a load of other Lads come down from
another school yeah there's about four
of us and we're having a cigarette and
no one carded you no carded me then so
I'm having a cigarette and he's allowed
to come down with us up and he'd come in
one of them whacked someone someone
whacked someone so he obviously gets
stuck in that could have been the end of
your life yeah when it was the beginning
it was right it was so he pulled his
hood over he's gone whack with his hand
on me and anyway I wake up
I wake up in hospital I've got a lot of
sticks in here but I've got a double
mouth so that was a blessing right yeah
I heard that because you've been whacked
over the head yeah you had a lot of
stitches you get out of math classes
yeah yeah no I didn't like no I mean you
like getting out of yeah getting out of
that I might go that double English as
well but after that in my head I believe
I started hearing music man so let me
understand something because I was in a
music at all I was playing football and
I find this fascinating you Noah was
always into music he was playing guitar
he was sort of a loner yeah right you
were more of a social kind of guy I was
more playing football on the park being
a little [__] letting people's tires
down knocking on doors running away and
just being a little [__] and you never
were really that into music and I
thought music was for weirdos man right
you never sat there in your room and
listened to beetles and stones and sort
of became one of those record nerds or
anything like that no Noel was off he
was learning the guitar trying to you
know get his [__] together yeah you're
off doing your thing this kid hits you
in the head with a hammer and you say
you wake up and suddenly what you heard
music yeah just no it wasn't instantly
it's just like the next couple I just I
was going [__] you know that's I think
it was Madonna Like A Virgin I was going
I said [__] tune actually yeah and
not so a week before and I'd be going
like I wouldn't it wouldn't even got
that close you know what I mean how do
you remember doing that who knows man
but whoever he was thank you for it you
know what I mean don't you I mean that's
like saying that it hit hit you in the
head and unlock something exactly I'm
telling you it's like when people come
out of columns they start speaking
Japanese yeah oh Russian you know what I
mean yes I mean that and so we took 100
legitimate that all of a sudden 100 all
of a sudden I heard Like a Virgin by
Madonna was going that's a [__]
change and where do you go when you're
kind of a tough kid growing up where do
you go to sing when you you know you
never sang before you were a kid who
played football once you get hit over
the head where do you go to work this
out do you join a band oh no we just I
was just I was always yeah you just sing
around the house you know what I mean
really and then we might start at a band
which I was impressed with or not you
know what I mean so they got rid of
their singer
and they put you in they said you won't
come down because I had to look in that
so I went down there you got to look so
I went down there did you feel
self-conscious when you first started
singing yeah I still do feel a bit odd
singing it's an odd thing I do in it you
know I mean it's very personal in that
book so growing up yeah the way I
understand it your brother Noel he
wasn't in your band at first you had
your own thing going on yeah your
brother's off being a roadie for some
band yeah and you guys start a band and
he comes home one day and he goes holy
[__] my brother can sing he had no clue
you could sing he was shocked yeah and
still he's still shocked by that by that
fact did they get along when they were
younger was there no no they didn't
never no they shared a bedroom he said
the bedroom and I pissed he bought this
new sound system and I'd been out
drinking like about 15 and had maybe a
little too many cherries and I'd come in
and I had a spliff as well I mean
[__] room is spinning I've got all
part of the bed on the [__] wall
where's the [__] light switch right I
couldn't find the light switch and I
thought oh [__] I'm just gonna have to
go man so I Just Whipped it out pissed
all over these [__] new sound system
and he's gone where the [__] are you
doing I was just having a [__] piss
in it is I'm a [__] new [__]
steady I was like and I was like I'll
[__] said I won't it oh my God I
think that's where I think it was a good
friend that was a long time ago and
you're not kidding you think that that
pissing incident where you peed all over
his new sense and don't forget he was a
kid who hung out in his bedroom that
sound system was important that was a
Holy Grail yeah yeah you've got to go
you gotta go mate yeah I mean I ain't
pissing in my Paddington Bear pajamas
for no one did you ever exactly did you
ever apologize to your brother for
peeing on his sound equipment did you
ever say listen yeah yeah listen I was
drunk I was 15. for Christ's sakes I
apologize can we get past this I said
listen mate it's for it was either the
sound system or your [__] head
your mouth and I know he sleeps with his
mouth open so you'd take it or [__]
leave it my son